Khloe Kardashian makes her first public
appearance since her pregnancy news
broke the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star stepped out for her
first public appearance on Saturday I
just want to live my life and be happy
following the news that she is expecting
her first child with boyfriend Tristan
Thompson it's just above the 33 year old
reality star attended the one-year
anniversary celebration of her good
American denim line at Nordstrom in
Century City California I'm having so
much fun and looked absolutely stunning
I love it
the blonde beauty covered up her growing
baby bump with a black jacket and
matching pair of the brand's leggings
complete with layered gold necklaces a
Chanel chain belt and black Christian
Louboutin heels Kardashian also shared a
series of snaps before the event
[Music]
and as she got dolled up with her glam
squad but that's the fun of it
on Sunday the Revenge body host posted a
series of photos from the event on
Instagram writing quote happy
Anniversary to us that's just really
exciting for me but I have super fun
while she has yet to confirm the baby
news herself here like the last person
we can tell things to a source tells ET
quote this is something she has wanted
for a long time and finally the timing
is right
[Music]
you